E
NEW VIDEO WE WILL SHOW YOU
TONIGHT ON THIS PROGRAM BUT
FIRST, WE'VE GOT TO BEGIN WITH
SOME BREAKING NEWS IN A SHOCKING
NEW REPORT SURROUNDING THE
JOHN KERRY ON THE WORLD'S
LEADING STATE SPONSOR OF
TERRORISM THAT WOULD BE IRAN,
ACCORDING TO LEAKED AUDIO
OBTAINED BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THE TOP
DIPLOMAT CLAIMS THAT JOHN KERRY
COMPROMISED ONE OF OUR TOP
ALLIES AND US IN THE PROCESS BY
DIVULGING POTENTIALLY TOP-SECRET
HIGHLY SENSITIVE INFORMATION
"FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
JOHN KERRY INFORMED HIM THAT
ISRAEL HAD ATTACKED IRANIAN
INTEREST IN SYRIA AT LEAST 200
TIMES.
TO HIS ASTONISHMENT.
DID JOHN KERRY REVEAL ISRAELI
COVERT ACTIONS TO ISRAEL AND THE
U.S.'S SINGLE BIGGEST ENEMY, THE
NUMBER ONE STATE SPONSOR OF
TERRORISM WORLDWIDE?
THAT WOULD MEAN ALL PLAUSIBLE
DENIABILITY FOR A COVERT
OPERATION WOULD BE DEAD, GONE,
AND BURIED.
ASSETS ON THE GROUND RISKING
THEIR LIVES, THEY WOULD BE IN
IMMINENT DANGER IF THEY HADN'T
ALREADY BEEN MURDERED, SOMETHING
WE LIKELY WOULDN'T KNOW AND OF
COURSE JOHN KERRY IS SAYING THIS
NEVER HAPPENED,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS STANDING
BY, THE ACCURACY OF THEIR
REPORTING.
KEEP IN MIND, REPORTEDLY HAD
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH IRANIAN
OFFICIALS EVER SINCE LEAVING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SO IT'S
ONLY A PROBLEM IF YOU ARE
CONSERVATIVE OR REPUBLICAN.
AND THEN IT'S A VIOLATION OF THE
1799 LOGAN ACT WHICH BY THE WAY
YOU GO BACK TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, STILL IN
COMMUNICATION WITH IRAN MY
REALLY?
WHAT IF THE TRUMP SUPPORTER'S
WERE DOING THAT NOW?
ACCUSED HIM RIGHTLY SO OF
UNDERMINING OUR FOREIGN POLICY,
THAT'S OUR NATIONAL SECURITY AND
AFTER ALL, IT APPEARED THAT HE
WAS TRYING TO PRESERVE HIS
CROWNING ACHIEVEMENT, THE NOW
DEFUNCT DUMBEST DEAL IN THE
HISTORY OF MANKIND, THE IRANIAN
NUCLEAR DEAL THAT JOE BIDEN
WANTS TO LEAD BACK INTO, THE ONE
THAT GAVE $150 BILLION IN CASH
AND OTHER CURRENCY TO THE
LEADING STATE SPONSOR OF
TERRORISM AND IN EXCHANGE, WE
GOT NOTHING.
U.S.-LED CHECKS ON NUCLEAR
SITES, NONE.
ANYWHERE ANY TIME INSPECTIONS,
NONE.
ANY VERIFIABLE GUARANTEES, NONE.
EVEN OUR OWN INSPECTORS, NONE.
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
IRAN IMMEDIATELY WAS USING TO
FUND FURTHER TERROR ATTACKS ALL
OVER THE REGION AND WORLD.
REMEMBER THE ARCHITECT OF THIS
IDIOTIC DEAL HAS BEEN TRYING TO
APPEASE IRAN FOR OVER A DECADE
ALL WHILE VILIFYING OUR TOP ALLY
IN THE MIDDLE EAST, ISRAEL AT
EVERY TURN AND AS ONE ARTICLE IN
"THE NEW YORK POST" ENTITLED
JOHN KERRY IS SKIRTING THE LINE
OF TREASON WITH IRAN.
THE RATHER CURIOUS DEFINING
FEATURE GOING BACK AT LEAST FOUR
DECADES IS THAT OUR FRIENDS MUST
BE BULLIED COME OUR ENEMIES MUST
BE APPEASED.
NOT SHOCKING GIVEN THE TESTIMONY
YOU MIGHT RECALL WHEN HE RAN FOR
PRESIDENT WHEN THIS TAPE CAME UP
HIM IN THE 1970s ACCUSING HIS
FELLOW SOLDIERS IN VIETNAM OF
BEING MURDERERS, RANDOMLY
SHOOTING CIVILIANS, RAISING
IN -- REMINISCENT IN HIS WORDS
OF GENGHIS KHAN.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THEY PERSONALLY CUT OFF THE
EARS, CUT OFF HEADS, TAPED WIRES
FROM PORTABLE TELEPHONES TO
HUMAN AND TURNED UP THE POWER,
CUT OFF LIMBS, BLOWN UP BODIES,
RANDOMLY SHOT AT CIVILIANS,
RAZED VILLAGES IN THE FASHION
REMINISCENT OF GENGHIS KHAN.
>> Sean: CLEARLY JOHN KERRY
HAS NOT CHANGED AT ALL AND NOW
MULTIPLE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE
CALLING ON HIM TO RESIGN OR BE
INVESTIGATED, THAT'S THE LEAST
OF IT.
SENATOR SULLIVAN FROM ALASKA
AMONG MANY OTHERS, EVEN
MITT ROMNEY FOUND A LITTLE BIT
OF COURAGE SOMEWHERE, POPPED OUT
FOR A SECOND TO CRITICIZE A
DEMOCRAT AND WILL CALL FOR FULL
TRANSPARENCY, WHATEVER THAT
MEANS.
THE FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO BELIEVES IRAN'S TOP
DIPLOMAT MIGHT BE FREQUENTLY OUT
OF THE LOOP WITH THE RULING
FACTION HAS LITTLE POWER,
FREQUENTLY LIES WHICH MEANS EVEN
HIS ALLEGED ATTEMPTS TO
UNDERMINE OUR CLOSEST ALLY MIGHT
HAVE BEEN FRUITLESS, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY ANYBODY
LISTENS TO HIM, HE HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH IRANIAN FOREIGN
POLICY, LIES ALL THE TIME.
>> Sean: REGARDLESS OF HIM AND
JOHN KERRY, IT'S NOW CLEAR THAT
THE HOSTILE REGIME IN IRAN IS
TESTING THIS NEW ADMINISTRATION.
THE WEAK, FRAIL, COGNITIVELY
STRUGGLING JOE AND KAMALA HARRIS
THERE LAST NIGHT IN THE
PERSIAN GULF, THREE IRANIAN
REVOLUTIONARY GUARDS PATROL
BOATS PLOWED THROUGH WATERS
TOWARDS U.S. NAVAL SHIPS AND
WHAT THE NAVY CALLED IN
UNNECESSARILY CLOSE RANGE WITH
UNKNOWN INTENT.
AFTER RADIO LOUDSPEAKER WARNINGS
WERE IGNORED, FORCED TO FIRE
SEVERAL WARNING SHOTS AT THAT
TIME, THE IRANIAN VESSELS
FINALLY RETREATED BUT NO DOUBT
THIS WILL NOT BE THE LAST TIME
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS